hello everyone i last week uploaded a
youtube video that was of a bunch of
gaming news that i thought that i felt
very positively about and so i thought
why don't i just do that once a week
just to upload things that i think are
really cool i feel like so much of
youtube is just very
negative in terms of gaming news and
some of that is certainly justified um
but i never like feel like i'm adding
anything when i cover those stories
because a million youtubers have already
covered them and i just don't feel like
i have anything else to say
this story is awesome and still
developing um so we're on reddit right
now this is reddit user sadfutago so
this user
posted this user sad futago um two
months ago which is a long time and it's
worth noting hello how do you open the
church
hello i'm your writer i want to know how
to open the church in near automata
um and as somebody who has played near
automata multiple times
don't recall any church to be opened and
someone asked at what point in the story
are you
he said we are doing side quests until
we can figure out how to open the
hallway for him i think the main story
is when the pod tells you to go to the
resistance camp after 82 wakes up from
the fight and it's clearly
we'll get to the video but it's clearly
like a certain point in the game where
you finish the adam fight and there's
the environment's very strange around
this area so then next
this is the church area that i was
talking about that is in the door after
you beat adam in the copied city
underground area the door open button
doesn't show up for my friend for the
hallway entrance
uh this is not an environment that
actually exists in near automata this is
somebody who has just posted this being
how do i open the church my friend can't
find it and then a follow-up here saying
the church area i was talking about with
pictures
um
of something that
nobody else has seen
this isn't in the game this originally
got removed that's so funny that's so
funny the auto mod deleted the post
that's amazing um but still not really a
lot of responses because
while he was somehow become the church
guy on the neurotomer subreddit
uh it's a month ago nobody even really
found this yet i think this is a second
month ago post yeah this one's on the on
neo subreddit rather than on new
automata hello does anyone know how to
open up the doors to get to this area in
the copied city i can open the hallway
doors fine but my friend who's at the
same part of the game as me can't open
it i asked some people about this and
they said my friend hasn't done an
objective yet do you know which one so
he's trying to figure out what objective
his friend has not done to get to this
area we don't even know how he got there
uh so
this did start a month ago where people
are starting to be like dude what um op
could you please tell your friend to
upload a video on how they reached that
point so we can replicate tara himself
confirmed there are no other easter eggs
to be found and if that location was
indeed part of the normal game and not
some kind of leftover dev asset i think
after almost six years we would have
found it especially in the data mining
also as an artist myself the images are
a bit suss to me but i would be glad to
be proven otherwise yokotaro
the director of
nia did come out and say that every
single easter egg for neurotomato had
already been found
so finding that he could be lying
yokotaro is the kind to do that i will
tell you i did a panel with the nier
team a few years ago and i co-wrote it
with yokotaro like together
in the room in a back room at pax we
were writing jokes for this panel and
that was probably one of the highlights
of my entire career is sitting down with
yokotaro
no mask
writing jokes together
super fun and i do think that this he'd
be the kind of guy who's like you found
them all just just to throw a bone so
then they oh they post this video
which is how this
really blew up and again i don't think
that this user is playing some kind of
long con
how do you receive password
this is this is
two months of just being like hey how do
you get to the church
it's so innocent
so he posts this video uh it says hello
here is the video of the path to the
church hallway door i started from the
beginning of the copied city and then go
to the boss area where adam is
this is all
environments that people will have seen
from that fight and i guess i like i
didn't explore this area but it's still
factors this doesn't exist for anyone
else
here is where he claimed
the church door is and i guess it is
and
nobody else
has again ever found this someone here
goes i'm gonna be honest i don't think
this is real why'd you cut the video
right off before going in all the way
that would be because this person this
user still doesn't understand that this
is not a thing anybody can
just go to uh why don't you use some
sort of screen capture software i think
it's a kid why do we only get snippets
of one wall in your pictures if i was
going to fake an area of the game this
would be the easiest place to do it as
low effort models will still pass here
just saying going to need some more
evidence hello i have a usb now and i
deleted terraria i think i have space to
make a longer video and they showed me
how to screen record the ps4 game and
put it on usb
isn't it mod good question twitch chat
no
um for this to be a mod
it would be
so beyond what anyone has done in the
modding community for this game
that the modders haven't even figured
out how to replicate it so it would be
a mod that is like a game changer for
near automata
in that nobody else knows how they did
it nobody has been able to mod anything
like this before and again you haven't
even actually seen it yet this is the
actual ps4 one i think
um so where they go open this door
this is obviously the inside of this
room
again
if this is a mod
it's the most detailed
map editing mod that nia has ever had
and how
has nobody else managed to do anything
like this
it has to be cut content
and it's so cool
there's a video about a never seen
before room in a five-year-old game
makes a community go batshit crazy
refuses to elaborate further leaves they
clearly just don't understand reddit and
made a reddit account for the purposes
of
talking about this like i think that's
so cute i just feel like it makes it so
much better is this real because i can't
remember anything like this
has anyone found evidence of map mods
remotely this advanced though no and
that's the thing again there's nothing
less advanced in in the modern community
veneer at this point i know mod feels
like an arkham razer in this situation
but until equivalent mod modding tools
are found i think it's more likely this
is real combination of mods in photoshop
you could i guess
someone said is this the church the guy
was referring to they found model data
for a uh copied city church
um but people confirmed that that is a
separate model it's not the same model
uh if this is truly a secret so well
hidden that nobody else knows about it
and based on modern input this seems
like it might be the case that means it
requires an insanely specific set of
condition slash inputs to initially
unlock that op just somehow managed to
do without realizing it and could
probably never describe what it did to
unlock this and this is definitely the
case and and this is what i think is
true and why i think this story is so
cool is that it's so wholesome this
isn't somebody trying to trick people
that we know of yet it just comes across
as somebody innocently coming across
something and the statistical likelihood
of them coming across this in this game
is so low and it's like a big part of
what qa does and a big problem with bugs
what he's found is effectively a bug it
could span like
hours like it could be six hours of
inputs in specific orders that made this
door trigger and he would never have any
way of recounting what they are it's a
big part of why players can be really
bad at reporting bugs because they go i
go to inventory and game crash
but sometimes it's something four hours
before that that actually triggered that
crash uh when you opened your inventory
so there's no way that he if this is
this innocent person who has comments
where he's like talking about his mum
and and comes across as a kid to me just
played through me and was trying to help
his friend figure out how to get to the
church
again i really hope this is true because
i just think it's so wholesome that the
whole community is just like freaking
out and excited about this thing that's
so innocent it's just extremely unlikely
that he would ever be able to replicate
or even detail how he got there because
of the way video games work you would
have to know all of your button inputs
potentially for hours wild think you can
reverse engineer the game we can find
out the side quests that you have to do
to unlock the door which is really cute
because they still think that there was
a side quest to unlock the door and
there's not there isn't there is no side
quest i mean i guess there's a chance
that this could be somebody who's like a
very very very good modder
who is also um like smart enough to mod
it that well but also to like play a kid
like role player kid on reddit it just
seems really unlikely if you were gonna
do this why wouldn't you just take
credit for it leaning towards that op is
playing on a dev build of the game and
this is a self-marketing campaign it is
coming out on switch soon it's possible
everyone is talking about nier i wonder
if someone has told yokotaro how do you
know yokotaro isn't the guy posting this
uh lance mcdonald friend of mine
i know the modest say that level modding
is nowhere near this correct i'm leaning
to this being real op either doesn't
know how to replicate this or know how
they triggered this to begin with or
they're being an asset not sharing how
they did it and leading towards the
former yeah i don't i don't get that
impression this is good content then
this is the church
well reverse engineer is not that's a
pretty advanced thing to say i don't
know hello i get lots of messages and i
can't read them all this video took a
long time to upload it's for the guy who
asked for a long video of the whole way
to the church after the whole i can't
kill the black lobby i can only walk
through him i don't think there's
anywhere else to go after the place i
fair yep good input but i mean i want to
read his comments people who posted it
said it's either cut content or a mod
but maybe it can be a viral marketing
campaign it's a strange thing to say
it's either cut content or it is a mod
did you accidentally stay in the same
account or are you just not
understanding what you're reading
it's entirely possible that he just
doesn't know what it means can you tell
me how to open it no one knows how to
open the church door
oh it's so good so obviously kind of
remains to be seen and i'm sure a lot of
people will do a lot of effort to debunk
this um
to see whether it's not actually or
whether it is a mod that again someone
has figured out somehow if it is some
kind of marketing campaign
or whatever there are a lot of options
here but for the most part i just think
that this is super exciting like i've
been reading these comments a ton um
today specifically when i found out
about this as a huge neo fan
reading people like theorizing about
what it is and how he got there and
people trying to replicate it on their
own consoles and not being able to it's
just like very cool to see this
community and this person who seems to
be so innocent and is being very polite
try to get to the bottom of this thing
with the game that came out six years
ago they had a post get removed i just i
just love it i just felt like it it was
the vibes were very good
um
and it really does come across as just a
kid being like
this is what people are saying but they
don't understand what that implies of
them could be either technically could
be either
i just love the story i thought it was
really fun the reactions are really fun
i just uploaded a video on paw to get it
is right behind where you fight adam so
he didn't find out the objective says an
odd machine investigate the suspicious
machine well that's probably just an
actual neoquest right near an odd
machine weird machine is a friendly unit
in near automata serves as the unit
client for idiot savant
there is weird machine odd machine could
be a translation potentially sorry there
is a spelling mistake in the title i
meant with doors instead of doors like
this comment right here sorry it's
placed in the underground copied city
where you fight boss adam i can open the
door in church area fine but my friend
who's at the same part of the game as me
cannot open it and thinking about how
that came about is just so cute too
we're both using a2 we can both go
inside the copied city past the elevator
but i don't know how i opened the church
inside the copied city you might be
right about the objective because i beat
the game without going into the church
hallway before so i think you can miss
an objective or something to open it
technically correct the objective is
probably just a lot of very
unpredictable inputs i love it